what about not being healed from a
relationship and going into another
relationship should the focus be on
working on yourself until you've healed
well look i think it's not possible to
to fully heal from a past relationship
without having new relationships and it
doesn't have to be romantic
relationships we heal relationally right
because if we've had trust broken or if
we felt betrayed or if we've lost hope
how are we going to heal that on our own
like we need connection so that we can
remind ourselves and reaffirm that love
is safe that connection is safe we
really do require relationship as human
beings most of us enter into
relationships with unhealed stuff from
the past like i've not yet met a person
who doesn't have something that that
isn't quite resolved um
painful experience or memory that might
be lingering underneath the surface or
that might be causing some hesitancy to
let go and that's just the nature of
being human and taking leaps and you
know experimenting in love